allez les bleus frankreich steht im
halbfinale der fußball weltmeisterschaft
das team von trainer didier dechamps
setzte sich im ersten viertelfinalspiel
der wm in russland mit 2 zu 0 gegen
uruguay durch vor den pariser champs
élysées ist nach dem aufgeraute jubelten
die fans der equipe tricolore
[Applaus]
ich bin super happy
wir sind im halbfinale das hat es seit
2006 nicht mehr gegeben
jetzt werden wir die ganze nacht
durchfeiern und wir bleiben in russland
bis zum finale
ein kopfballtreffer durch raphael varane
brachte frankreich in der vierten minute
in führung
antoine griezmann erhöhte nach einem
saftigen patzer von torwart fernando
muslera in der zweiten halbzeit zum 2 0
einige europäische fans in nischni
novgorod waren am freitag in tränen
aufgelöst andere touristen fassung ich
bin muslim aber für evtl
und jetzt haben wir verloren es ist
nicht ohne cavani ist alles ziemlich
kompliziert aber wir haben es wenigstens
versucht top-stürmer edin samt aber nie
einer der schlüsselspieler uruguays war
wegen einer wadenverletzung ausgefallen